take a moment to look at this image
what do you see
just a neural network
perhaps you spotted the hidden figure
if so you have just had a moment of
insight
you may have felt a similar jolt when
discovering the solution to a math
problem
understanding a joke or metaphor or
realizing something unexpected about
yourself
these aha moments occur when your brain
spontaneously reinterprets information
to reach a novel non-obvious conclusion
nessa bryce painted neurons a few years
ago for an art exhibit
she had designed the piece to portray
the idea that our brain's neural
networks make us who we are after
joining psychologist james t ends vision
laboratory at the university of british
columbia in 2013
she had her own abrupt realization
she recognized how her art could inform
science
using this piece along with other hidden
object images she investigated how a
person's focus and attention change when
experiencing an unexpected revelation
creative people have sudden
breakthroughs instances when they are
able to recombine information in a new
and useful way
scientists view these flashes of insight
as markers of the creative process
and observing them in the laboratory
elucidates what happens in the brain
during problem solving
a story is emerging about all the
factors that lead up to an insight says
cognitive psychologist john cunos who
studies creativity at drexel university
what researchers are finding is that the
contemporary science of creativity
largely bolsters an almost century-old
theory
in 1926 political scientist graham
wallace defined the creative process as
four distinct stages
preparation
incubation
illumination and verification
since then scientists have broken some
of his stages into substages to reveal
distinct cognitive processes
for example preparation now consists of
two parts one involving general learning
and the other more focused on skill
building these stages really seem to be
universal whether you are a scientist
artist writer or musician says harvard
university psychologist shelly carson
who has interviewed more than a thousand
creative people for her research
and creativity is not restricted to a
subset of highly talented artists and
thinkers carson says
these innovative people have a distinct
style of thinking and breaking down
their approach can allow anyone to
recreate the process
brain research has revealed that we can
all get closer to achieving that magical
spark of insight with the help of a few
simple techniques
roughly speaking people solve problems
in one of two ways
they either tend to rely on moments of
insight or they approach them
analytically
answering questions with analysis
involves finding solutions through
deliberate methodical trial and error
whereas insight is perceived as an
abrupt epiphany
both methods are useful but insight is
typically seen as the best option for
out-of-the-box solutions
kunios and his colleagues monitored the
brain activity of 26 study participants
using electroencephalography or eeg
while they sat quietly in a room
after recording these electrical signals
the researchers asked the participants
to try to solve 180 anagram problems
which involved reorganizing a word such
as west to form another word like stew
subjects also reported whether they had
used an insightful or analytical
approach to solve each problem
cunios found that the brain activity of
people who used insight
differed significantly from that of
people who preferred the analytical
approach
before they even began solving problems
most members of the insight group
exhibited less activity in the occipital
lobe a region involved in visual
processing compared with the analytical
set
specifically the brains in the insight
group showed less activity in the
so-called alpha wave range which
reflects neural inhibition and the beta
one wave range which is linked with
selective visual attention
in other words these findings suggest
that people who rely on insight tend to
experience diffuse visual attention when
they're not actively engaged in a task
in a way this study along with carson's
reports from highly creative individuals
suggests that to prime your brain for
creativity you should wander the world
with an open mind
gathering a broad base of knowledge is
the first stage of the creative process
which usually comes naturally to people
through intellectual curiosity carson
says
another way to break your thought habits
is by asking questions such as how can i
do this differently and by stepping
outside your comfort zone
a poet with writer's block for example
might be advised to take up a new hobby
such as scuba diving or dance lessons
neuroscientist turned artist greg dunn
discovered an entirely different way to
depict the brain when he began studying
sumi a art an asian style of painting
his experimentation with the style's
free-flowing ink led to a simple yet
elegant new method for painting neurons
yet simply exposing yourself to new
things does not seem to be the full
story
according to a study by sergio agnoli
and his colleagues at the marconi
institute for creativity at the
university of bologna in italy
how you engage thoughts that arise
through new experiences is important for
facilitating creativity they found that
people who can deliberatively engage in
focused mental exploration come up with
more original solutions to problems than
those who reported little ability to
control how their mind wanders
therefore building a solid foundation
from which creativity can grow requires
both exposing yourself to new
experiences and intentionally engaging
with the thoughts and feelings that
arise as a result
psychologist dean keith simonton of the
university of california davis has
linked creativity with the acquisition
of expertise
he compared the cumulative years of
experience of 59 opera composers with
their aesthetic success he measured
aesthetic achievement in eight different
ways
tallying the number of times an opera
was recorded and performed in major
opera houses for example as well as the
number of pages devoted to the work in
opera histories
simonton found that a composer's years
of musical experience were a powerful
predictor of an opera's acclaim
he also found that if the composer had
already created a number of other works
within the same genre this would
actually hurt the opera's critical
reception and legacy
in other words solutions to great
problems demand practice skill and study
yet creative solutions occur when
someone applies their experience to new
domains whether you are proving fermat's
last theorem or planning a birthday
party finding novel solutions involves a
little advanced research
how much preparation you will need will
vary but the more you know about a
problem the better equipped you are to
solve it
some of the most creative minds in
history were masters of their respective
fields
given that these people spent large
amounts of time immersed in their
studies one of the best ways to maximize
your creativity
is to find an area you would like to
develop an expertise in
then begin to follow that passion
once you have immersed yourself in a
problem the best way to come up with a
creative solution is to stop consciously
thinking about it kunios and his
colleagues used functional magnetic
resonance imaging to record the brain
activity of 44 people as they solved 185
remote association problems
these word puzzles require finding a
single word that can pull together three
seemingly unrelated words
for example the solution to foam
deep and salt
is
c
after finding an answer the subjects
reported whether they had solved the
problem using insight or analysis
cunos found that in the two seconds
before a problem appeared the insight
users prepared for the challenge by
shifting from their scattered outward
attention to an inward focus
puzzles solved insightfully were
preceded by increased activation in the
anterior cingulate cortex a brain region
that monitors internal attention to
different ideas
among other things
in contrast tasks solved analytically
were preceded by significant activity in
the occipital lobe which handles visual
processing
this increase indicates that the
analytical solvers concentrated more on
what they were looking at
research from the university of
amsterdam and the university of bologna
in italy has demonstrated that sleeping
on a problem or stepping away from it
and then immersing yourself in an
alternative activity can help you
unconsciously cultivate creative
solutions
taken together the findings reveal a
benefit to forcing your brain to shift
gears or look within
one reason might be that your attention
can then be captured by a surprising
solution your unconscious mind has been
ruminating on
so take a nap or try your hand at
something new
history is replete with examples of
creative individuals who describe being
hit with inspiration while daydreaming
or attending to a different task
writer robert louis stevenson and
musician paul mccartney for instance
used dreams as starting points for new
works
many day-to-day problems can be solved
this way which explains why so many
people recall stumbling on ideas while
taking a shower driving to work or
walking
when insight hits
certain changes happen in the brain
psychologist mark beeman of northwestern
university led a study that measured
people's brain activity with fmri and
eeg during the moment of insight
as in kunios's studies participants
tackled
remote association problems and then
indicated if they had cracked the
problem using insight
the results showed significantly
increased activity in the anterior
superior temporal gyrus of the right
hemisphere at the critical moment when
the solution appeared in comparison to
problem solvers who did not experience
such an aha moment
this gyrus is a prominent ridge on the
cortex of the right hemisphere and it
plays a fundamental role in recognizing
distant connections between words
the activity surge in the right but not
the left lobe may also be meaningful
according to the researchers there are
areas in the right side of your brain
that interpret information more loosely
than areas on the left side
this means that the information is less
tightly defined allowing you to access
other concepts more readily which is a
key component of creativity
both hemispheres are working all the
time but parts of your right hemisphere
might loosely define a cat as a mammal
making it easy to see how a cat relates
to say an elephant
parts of your left hemisphere however
might describe a cat as a small
carnivorous mammal with soft fur a short
snout and retractile claws
something very different from an
elephant
research has suggested that you can tip
the scales toward a looser style of
understanding by describing objects or
issues in unusual ways
for example by thinking of a hanger as a
long twisted wire instead of as a
metallic instrument for hanging coats
you might discover other uses for it
try this technique every so often as you
are actively working to solve a problem
it might help prime your brain to forge
connections between distant concepts
the moment of insight is also
accompanied by a burst of alpha activity
in the visual cortex according to
beeman's study
alpha activity inhibits neuron firing
meaning that during a breakthrough your
brain is less involved in processing
visual information perhaps because
visual stimuli can be distracting
these findings suggest that you could
help your brain discover an insight
simply by closing your eyes
probably the most famous moment of
insight in history is archimedes eureka
legend has it that the ancient greek
mathematician had been challenged to
figure out whether a crown that king
hero ii of syracuse had commissioned was
made out of solid gold
archimedes was preparing a bath when he
discovered how to measure an object's
volume and thus its density after
noticing the displacement of water as he
climbed into the tub
although the story may be apocryphal it
has gone down in history in part because
it illustrates perfectly how insight
strikes
once you have had a moment of insight
you might find yourself feeling elated
a study by tufts university researcher
tad brunier showed that subjects who
came up with broad associations between
words such as associating pipe with
flute rather than smoke experienced a
boost in mood
take advantage of the positive mood to
check whether your solution works
when you have an insight it comes with a
lot of conviction carson says
so you really have to be objective and
evaluate that idea
this stage is an ideal time to bounce
ideas off of trusted friends
their feedback and support could help
you determine how well your solution
works
we'll discuss how creativity is
collective in an upcoming lecture
do not be discouraged though if your
personal eureka is less than perfect
creative people often describe going
through many failures before reaching a
successful solution
those failures helped to inform the end
result
making them a necessary step in the
process
when a student asked chemist and
two-time nobel laureate linus pauling
how he came up with so many good ideas
pauline replied
i have a lot of ideas and throw away the
bad ones
in practice each stage does not always
follow easily from the one before it
many people have to revisit earlier
steps several times before hitting on
inspiration
but ultimately the process is very
rewarding
creativity not only makes creators happy
but also benefits all those who will
enjoy their creations
the joys of an aha moment may even serve
a deeper purpose
in 2013 psychologists claudia mooth and
claus christian carbon of the university
of bomberg in germany found that
participants who identified a hidden
face in a picture liked the image more
than those who did not identify the face
muse hypothesizes that insight is
rewarding for evolutionary reasons
she says it could explain why we explore
the world and why we have interest in
things that are new
being curious and pursuing creative
endeavors
provides you with the opportunity to
discover new interests explore
unfamiliar territory develop expertise
and take breaks
in short working to develop and maximize
your creativity serves to enrich your
life
as carson puts it once you realize that
you can be creative it opens up this
whole new world